So, Luka, we got the one minute drill for you.
You ready?
Yeah.
All right, here we go.
Let's get one minute on the clock.
I know you're a car guy.
Your favorite car to drive.
That I have or that I want?
That you want.
Bugatti.
Alright.
Favorite restaurant here in Dallas?
Nick & Sam's.
Favorite subject in school?
Sports, how do you say it?
Recess.
As a kid, your favorite basketball player?
European, Spanoulis.
As a kid, your favorite soccer player?
Ronaldo.
Best advice a coach has ever given you.
Enjoy the game.
What other professional sport would you like to play?
Soccer.
Alright.
Which one do you prefer?
Cats or dogs?
Dogs.
Vanilla or chocolate?
Chocolate.
Morning person or night?
Night.
Barbecue or seafood?
Barbecue.
Sweet tea or unsweet tea?
Unsweet tea.
Favorite thing to do on your day off?
Lay on the couch.
The sporting event you'd most like to attend?
World Cup.
And if you could go to one more concert in your entire life, who would you go and see?
It's a tough one.
A Serbian singer.
I don't know.